[Musik]
hallo farbe den meiler torten welt schön
dass ihr heute auch wieder der
beidseitig möchte euch jetzt kurz vor
silvester ein paar silvester videos
machen und zwar ist es bei uns so dass
wir uns meistens mit freunden und mit
der familie treffen und dann den ganzen
abend spielen oder essen und alles
zusammen und ich habe mir gedacht dass
ich euch ein paar snacks zeige die man
erstens gut vorbereiten kann und die
zweitens auch so einem warmen oder
kalten buffet richtig cool land kommen
und bald möchte ich jetzt eben damit
starten
ich möchte euch heute käsestangen zeigen
das sind so richtig schöne knusprige
stammen dem er eben mit dips servieren
kann und zeige ich einfach mal die
zutaten dafür an zutaten braucht ihr 100
gramm mehl 100 gramm butter und 100 watt
also von allen die gleiche menge ein
eigelb und jetzt noch ein paar gewürze
und zwar habe ich hier etwas
cayennepfeffer normalen pfeffer und salz
das ist jeweils zu etwa viertel
teelöffel und ja gesehen das sind ganz
wenige zutaten und ganz einfache zutaten
ich mache das jetzt eben in der kleinen
menge ist ja gleich wie viele stangen
dabei rauskommen
und dann könnt ihr eben das rezept wie
ihr wollt eben auch hochrechnen auf
mehrere personen aus dem ganzen zutaten
wird ihr zum teig geknetet das könnte
ein toter mit der hand machen oder mit
einem handrührgerät mit den knethaken
aber ich werde das jetzt heute im
thermomix machen weil es einfach viel
schneller geht und da müsste jetzt auch
groß auf nix achtung jetzt kommt einfach
alle zutaten zusammen in euren und mixed
ob oder eben in eine schüssel interesse
ihren part verknetet
[Musik]
und wenn ja auch nicht die ganze dann
darfst dir das ganze jetzt auf stufe
vier verhören derzeit soll ich dann
ziemlich fest seit ich hab das rezept
übrigens aus diesem buch party küche ich
habe es selbst noch nicht gemacht und da
steht das ist ein fester teig sein soll
meint eick sieht jetzt so aus aktuell
nicht fest da ist immer noch ziemlich
weich und ich denke das liegt auch daran
war das eigene leben je nach größe die
tätigkeit auch das heißt ihr gebt als
einfach noch so viele mädels so wie es
ihr eben den festen teil gehabt
ich denke da brauchen wir noch mal so
etwa 50 grad untertags dann richtig wenn
noch nicht mehr an euren händen klebt
also so wie jetzt der minister fest
genug und geht nicht mehr dann kann man
eigentlich schön aufräumt ich sollte ihn
jetzt auch nicht zu lange kneten das war
natürlich richtig schön kalt bleiben und
ich werde jetzt auf einer cd chorleiter
aus wollen deshalb den vorteil dass ich
dann einfach kein leben braucht und wenn
ja aber keine telefonate habt könnt auch
einfach etwas mein leben zum ausholen
der teig wird jetzt etwa fünf millimeter
breite ausgeräumt ich habe diese zwei
abstandshalter verlege ich euch auch in
der infobox und das besondere ist
einfach dass ich nicht gucken muss war
nicht die fünf millimeter erreicht habe
ich habe einfach diese zwei abstand
seite der lediglich rechts und links
daneben
in meinem ausbau statt das sich übrigens
auch ins silicon ausrutschte und dann
ist der teig richtig schön gleichmäßig
dick und ich muss natürlich darauf
aufpassen da wo ich dann einmal so und
dann lege ich sie mir hier noch mal hin
und wenn ihr gerade kante haben wird
schlag da einmal das silikon hatte um
und die einfachste methode des jetzt in
streifen zu schneiden ist die dass ihr
jetzt eure parcours oder backpapier
nehmen und das drüber redet dann wird es
einmal gedreht
dann habt ihr es praktisch schon auf
eure back matte und dann müsste das
schneiden auf der pack folie darf ich
aber nicht mit einem messer schneiden
und ich nehme mir immer ganz gern meine
metall genial und kann das schön gerade
könnten abschneiden und jetzt sollten
diese streifen etwa einen zentimeter
dick sein und so etwa zehn zentimeter
lang oder eben so lange wie ihr sie wird
[Musik]
so steht das dann in etwa aus und ich
persönlich finde es nicht schlimm wenn
sie nicht gleich lang sind so sieht es
auch ein bisschen handmade autos und
eben nicht so gekauft und die müssen
jetzt erstmal den kühlschrank für etwa
30 minuten damit sie wieder kalt werden
und wer ganz besonders kreativ sein will
kann die auch stadt sehen standen zu
schneiden könnte auch aus stechen mit
verschiedenen ausstellern und habe da
eben keine käsestangen sondern krise
plätzchen was natürlich genauso gut geht
und da habe ich jetzt ein eigelb und
habe einen kleinen schluck wasser dazu
gegeben so esslöffel und das für mich
und jetzt werden die stangen damit
bestrichen und jetzt nehmen wir euch ein
paar samen treibt ihn darüber wie nehme
niemandem haben besondere stück also
geriebenen parmesan kaufen wenig weil
ich erstens mal die trainerinnen den
packungen vermeiden will
die haben immer trennmittel mitteln
damit eben der käse nicht wieder
zusammenklebt wenn er schon geräten ist
und zwei des handy schmeckt einfach
besser
doch das kommt hier großzügig drauf sie
können dann auch noch mal mit drauf
geben
hier gebe ich noch ein bisschen gerne
auf ein paar drauf und so weiter die
stein jetzt im vorgeheizten ofen bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze etwa 15 minuten
gebacken ist der käse schön verlaufen
ist und sich so etwa goldbraun sind wenn
der käse schlagen ist jetzt fertig die
sind auch richtig schön knusprig wie ihr
sehen könnt und hören kann und wie
schmeckt mir richtig gut
wir sprechen sie ganz gut mit einem
quicktipp da zeige ich euch gleich
wieder geht und ihr könnt das ganze
recht ganz cool auf so einem holzbrett
auf servieren oder ihr steckt die stange
neben ihn und glas aber ich finds auch
einem holzbrett richtig schön und guckt
euch mal mein holzbrettern das hat mir
eine ganz treue zuschauer denn geschenkt
finde ich ganz süß und so würde ich das
jetzt auch auf meinen pathetisch stelle
und dieser typ passt wirklich super dazu
da kann man sich dann einfach die sticks
nehmen rein tippen und essen und jetzt
zeige ich euch einfach noch wie ich den
karibik mache aber natürlich könnt ihr
da jeden anderen tipp aufnehmen
ich habe zum beispiel mal 'ne väter
creme gemacht da verlege ich euch das
video hier oben und natürlich auch in
der infobox jetzt zeige ich aber einfach
mal die zutaten für den karibik und zwar
braucht ihr dafür etwas mal lese ich
habe jetzt so etwa 120 gramm ganz normal
meine nächste können und natürlich auch
selber machen
ich habe hier einen esslöffel
aprikosenmarmelade die ist ganz wichtig
für diese leichte süße dann braucht ihr
etwas essig ganz normalen essig zwei
esslöffel olivenöl natürlich etwas curry
cayenne pfeffer salz und pfeffer und ich
kann euch da die ganz genaue
mengenangaben gar nicht so richtig sagen
ihr müsst es nämlich immer mal wieder
abschmecken
jetzt gebe ich hier den esslöffel
aprikosenmarmelade mit dazu zwei
esslöffel olivenöl und ich gebe so etwa
zwei esslöffel
essig mit dazu eine gute prise
cayennepfeffer schwarzen körper ein
bisschen salz nicht zu schwer und
natürlich curry also da wo ich einiges
rein so etwa ein teelöffel das wird
jetzt alles wahr wird
[Musik]
und diese abzug großen marmelade gibt es
im ganzen wirklich so diese
geheimnisvolle süße und kein mensch
kommt drauf dass der aprikosen apparaten
steckt dann müsste das ganze mal
probieren und ich gebe da immer ganz
gerne etwas joghurt mit dazu
das macht das ganze nämlich so schön
frisch und eben nicht so schwer durch
die manege und ich nehme da ganz
normaler naturjoghurt dass ich jetzt ein
türkischer joghurt mit zehn prozent fett
aber an 35 wurde 1,54 joghurt geht
natürlich auch ich gebe es aber ein
esslöffel wird dazu das zehnprozentige
joghurt natürlich den vorteil dass der
etwas fester ist und das gesamte eben
nicht so flüssig wird dann nochmals
abschmecken
saubere luft und das war's dann schon
dann ist schon fertig werden können das
war kühl stellen bis sie ihn benutzt und
ich liebe einfach es selbstgemachte
chips und selbstgemachte sachen die eben
schnell gehen und supertoll schmecken
natürlich gibt es diese käses ticks auf
fertig zu kaufen aber erst mal finde ich
die immer viel zu fettig also wenn man
da rein weist diesen wirklich viel zu
fettig und so weiß ich was drin steckt
ihr habt schnell gemacht ich bin ja auch
berufstätig und haben viel zeit und kann
so was immer super vorbereitet und die
zutaten und die mengenangaben können
dann natürlich auch noch mal nachlesen
auf meinem blog auf www punkteten
welt.de und wenn euch dieses gericht
gefällt dieser kleine snack dann zeigt
mein video gerne lassen wir auch einen
kommentar und gebt mir eine bewertung
und die ganzen produkte und weitere
infos verlinke ich euch hier unten
hinter infobox und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal wieder befahren
[Musik]